bootleg cat podcast representing Detroit
not Brooklyn
Queen what's up y'all 17 years old yes
wow are you a senior in high school yes
homeschooling are we doing online school
shout out to you man mom's in the
building all right let's get right to it
let's have her she's side of Steve Lobel
so she got to be fired
let's go Lobel music group period period
hey
okay with the Detroit beat drop easy man
uh look if we locked in ain't no
switching up if you want smoke bro put
them in a blunt try to stack a meal did
it in a month yeah till I hit a bill
[__] I ain't did enough seeing all these
problems I ain't touched I had to go get
it all my Ops meal prep will be thing I
know chicken can't talk kid with a [__]
who lead the whole sick up dog [__] on
these [__]
little baby in Detroit they have the
scope on me the youngest with the motion
[__] they know about me yo Big Homie
and nobody want no bottom [__] don't
even be mad at me they got their own
problems [__] the fake we get to the bag
don't ever get attached in that mode
always trying to go don't play the
internet bitter [__] always throwing
shots until we send them back different
goals y'all gonna start comparing me to
this and that touchdown in your city Yes
mine till I give it back born a hoe you
gonna die ho you gotta live with that
ain't no competition with this girl they
know who winning that every trip to
Saxon spending 10 that ain't no
clearance right I don't do the subs it
ain't directed ain't respected only else
I took was living lavish off a lesson
got a baddie with me rocking Buffs heavy
flex and that's my bestie turn up cause
she couldn't do that with the X's new
Alex and Queen on Christian diorto body
bag dimmer Benz Billy what I be on table
full of bad boss [__] ain't no peons
probably pack a pocket full of prizes no
Lincoln's Queen
[Music]
No period big Brook 17 year olds out
rapping a lot of y'all grown men out
there man
there it is Brooklyn Queen uh which IG
Brooklyn Queen 03 make sure I follow me
were you born in 03 no okay
okay look that's the day of my birthday
July 3rd yeah what year oh five [__] I
graduated high school in 05.
Jesus all right go follower man boom hey
I know you just watched a new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week